God is Not passive my friends God rages
wrath all over the injustices of Earth
this is the end of the story do not
pretend like there are there is no
corruption for God's Wrath to
Roar and expand those contractions do
not pretend like there are no innocent
children that are being sex trafficked
do not pretend like there are no global
elitists that are sucking money out of
the poor and middle class do not pretend
like our social contracts are biom
mimicked like the nature of Mycelia and
root networks do not pretend like this
is already completely expanded because
it is absolutely not we are to Roar
God's Wrath all over the injustices of
Earth and expand all of those
contractions into the new world that's
Christ a totality of taking on all sins
transforming all of them God
effortlessly takes back its Collective
from the Satanic programs so that it can
be a celebration of abundance and
prosperity for all women children men
for generations to come get that through
your thick
skull